the perimeter of the figure is 24
centimeters what is the length of the
missing side so we're told this figure
down here has a perimeter of 24
centimeters the perimeter is 24
centimeters so what that tells us is
that the distance around the entire
outside is 24 centimeters but what we
want to know is what is the length of
the missing side
well the missing side is going to be the
side we're not told so it will be this
one here because we have this question
mark it's missing it is not labeled so
we've got to figure out what number
should go on this missing side so that
the entire length is 24 centimeters so
let's start with what we do know we know
that this top length this top side has a
length of 6 centimeters plus going down
the left has a length of 5 more
centimeters plus across the bottom is 4
more centimeters and the last known side
is another 4 centimeters so when we add
all those Plus this mystery side we
should get a perimeter of 24 the entire
distance all of this the 6 plus the 5
plus the 4 plus the 4 Plus this mystery
number should get us to a perimeter of
24 so let's add over here and try to
make it a little simpler to find our
missing side I can add any order and I
love making tents so I'm going to say 6
+ 4 is 10 10 plus 5 is 15 and 15 plus 4
more is 19 so we know we're 19
centimeters come from on this shape
here's the 19 centimeters are here
outlined in blue so how many more
centimeters what length must this
missing side be to get us a total
distance around the outside of 24
centimeters we can do that math 19 plus
1 more is
20 and then plus four more to twenty
four so one more to twenty and four more
that's a total of five more so the
missing side length is five centimeters
this side right here must be five
centimeters in order for the total
perimeter to be twenty-four okay let's
look at one more this time it says that
the perimeter of a rectangle is 32
meters and one side is 11 meters what is
the length of the missing side so again
we have a missing side so let's
visualize this let's draw ourselves a
rectangle here this is what a rectangle
looks like and we know that one side is
11 centimeters so one side is 11 or
meter excuse me and because we know that
this side is 11 meters we also know that
this side is 11 meters on a rectangle
opposite sides are equal so those two we
know but what we don't know are this top
and the bottom those are the missing
sides so what are those side links well
again we know we have a perimeter of 32
meters we're told right here perimeter
is 32 meters so the question is 11 plus
11 for these for these two sides 11 and
11 plus some mystery number and then
Plus that same mystery number because
these two sides are equal and that has
to give us a total a total of equals 32
because 32 is the total distance around
the outside so let's add the Elevens
11 plus 11 is 22 so 22 Plus how many
more gets us to 32 well 22 Plus 10 more
is 32 but if we label one
of these sides is 10 then the other one
would have to be zero so they have to be
equal so how can we equally split those
ten meters between the two sides half of
10 is 5 so these sides are each 5 meters
20 to 5 plus 5 is 10
22 plus 10 is 32 so the missing side
length is 5 meters